to some breaking news Russia says it's
suspending its U.N and turkey a broken
grain export deal with Ukraine the
country's defense Ministry says it is
pulling out due to recent attacks on its
Black Sea Fleet well Harry Fawcett joins
us from Keith Harry I know it's early
days we haven't known this for very long
but what can you tell us around this
news
well certainly uh no reaction yet coming
from the Ukrainian side and no reaction
as well to the accusations that Russia
was making throughout the day that
Ukrainian uh with the assistance they
said from Britain had attacked the Black
Sea feat in Sebastopol the the port in
Crimea which is obviously occupied by
Russia annexed by Russia uh in 2013 and
so that is the reason that they are
giving for having pulled out of this
grain deal this was a key breakthrough
really both in terms of Ukraine's
ability to export and then to harvest
its agricultural crops this Autumn and
in terms of World Food Supplies there
was a real uh Log Jam taking place in
southern Ukraine so key to grain to
sunflower oil to many agricultural
products used around the world and a
reason for some of these shortages and
spikes in food prices around the world
that was struck back in Late July it was
meant to last for 120 days potentially
be renewed on the 19th of November if
there were no objections from any side
for some days now Russia has been has
been objecting to the terms and the way
that it's been uh going on uh complaints
as well that Russia hadn't been able to
export its own agricultural products and
fertilizers and now in the light of this
attack which Russia said lightly damaged
a Minesweeper there are reports that the
damage was greater than that and coming
from both uh aerial and Seabourn
unmanned drones uh Russia is now pulling
out of this deal so as I say we're still
waiting to hear any reaction coming from
the ukrainians as far as the British are
concerned they're denying any
involvement in this morning's attack all
right Harry stand by we can bring our
viewers a little bit more on that attack
in the Black Sea that you mentioned
Russia says it repelled a Ukrainian
drone attack on Black Sea Fleet ships
docked in the Crimean city of Savannah
Master Paul that's what Harry was
talking about the Kremlin claims the
attack was carried out quote under the
guidance of British Specialists listen
to this
the cave regime carried out a terrorist
attack on ships of the Black Sea Fleet
and civilian ships that were on the
outer and inner roadsteds of the
Sebastopol base nine unmanned aerial
vehicles and seven autonomous Maritime
drones were involved in the attack
so Harry in light of what we just heard
I want to go back to what you were
telling us just a moment ago uh is there
any reason to believe that the British
at this stage were involved in any way
shape or form with this attack
well certainly Nothing substantiated by
the Russians uh no evidence yet provided
they said not only were the British
involved in this attack in the early
hours of Saturday morning they're also
claiming that British underwater teams
were involved in the sabotage of the
nordstream one and two pipelines in the
Baltic Sea uh a few weeks ago again
Britain is denying there's any
involvement in either of those events
and so the key thing now that the well I
suppose there are two big questions how
much damage really was done in this
attack and what kind of retaliation
militarily might there be by the
Russians because you'll remember just uh
at the beginning of the month with the
attack on the coach Bridge linking
Crimea and Mainland Russia uh the the
truck bomb that was used to severely
damage that bridge that was followed uh
just a couple of days later with heavy
air strikes on Kiev and other parts of
Ukraine but already it seems there is
retaliation and on this diplomatic
political economic level with the
decision by Russia to pull out of this
deal it is something that they would
seem to be edging towards over recent
days a lot more talk about this coming
from the Kremlin and now the defense
Ministry has announced that as a result
of this attack in Crimea they are
pulling out and Harry if you can take us
back just a little bit this deal was a
hardly thought agreement that was found
between Russia between Ukraine it was
mediated by turkey it was hard to get to
a point where it was where there was an
agreement to bring the grain out of the
region
it was on all sorts of levels on the
political level uh on the logistical
level a lot of talk about uh the
military dangers potentially for any uh
civilian shipping going in and out uh
from the the port areas in southern
Ukraine uh the amount of uh mines
floating in the water and the kind of uh
work that we need need to be done on
that front as well but it was seen as
crucial uh for Ukraine because the the
silos in which the previous year's
Harvest were still being stored were
still if not full at least uh very very
much in use to store the the previous
year's Harvest and with the new Harvest
coming up it could have been a major
economic in an agricultural problem here
in Ukraine and for the wider world uh
the amount of grain amount of sunflower
seed and sunflower oil in the world
economy coming from the fields of
Ukraine is substantial it's it's a major
part of that part of the the global
Staples that are required and so the
prices were spiking there was real
concern about Hunger especially in
Africa as a result of of this Log Jam
and so it was extremely important more
than 9 million tons of agricultural
products have already been shipped out
as a result of this deal and now it
looks like it's uh well for now it has
ended it's going to be extremely
difficult you'd imagine to get it back
up and running again from this point
absolutely Harry Fawcett reporting live
from Kiev on this breaking news thank
you very much Harry now let's bring in
rasool sirdar he's following this and
covering this for us from Istanbul
because rasul turkey was a key player in
getting this deal done
yeah indeed turkey for starting from the
the beginning on has been the mediator
particularly between Russia and and and
Ukraine and also uh with the UN as well
so in July
um these four parties somehow have been
able to managed to to to reach a deal
and in July it was signed so later
um then we have seen the the the ships
uh start to carry the the Ukrainian
grain to the global market and so but so
far after the announcement coming from
the Russian defense Ministry there
hasn't been yet any official statement
coming from the Turkish uh capital or
any of the other officials yet but
however as today is quite a busy day for
president everyone he's attending an
open opening ceremony of the the first
locally produced Turkish card which is
called talk and so all of the state
officials high levels including all of
the ministers are are now there so
probably right after that you're going
to hear the official reaction from
Ankara so the deal was reached in in
July and simply the mechanism was uh was
was being overseen by the United Nations
so according to that that the mechanism
according to the plan of the agreement
that they have reached the the ships
were carrying the Ukrainian grain
through the Black Sea and taking it to
Istanbul and in Istanbul there has been
a center established just for that
grains and then from that Center to the
global market but Russia by that time
had one condition that each of the ship
that is going to leave the end Ukrainian
Port must be suspected must be
investigated or checked by the Russian
naval forces and that have that has been
accepted by by Ukraine by that time so
we do not know what Russia now see any
security threat that they suspended deal
or any other reason so it's not clear at
this at this moment but so far hundreds
of thousands of ships have left the
Ukrainian poor cities and carried the
grave to the international market but
something that Russia has been quite
critical about and also we have seen
that it has resonated with President Abu
and as well from time to time they were
saying that these ships originally were
planned to mostly carry the grain to the
poor countries underdeveloped countries
the vulnerable countries but so far more
than half of them is going to the the
rich countries European countries and so
on that was a criticism toward the the
how the way how it was being practiced
but we do not know whether this is the
reason that Russia or is going to
provide or not as I said so it's going
to be quite a huge blow to the global
food security at this point it seems so
but at this point we also do not know
what the Moscow had any discussion with
Ankara in the way of getting to make
this decision or not or whether the
United Nations have been notified about
it or not but so far as I said we do not
have any official statement from Ankara
yet absolutely rasul sir darlook we
appreciate all the context around this
breaking news here on Al Jazeera that
Russia has just pulled out of a key deal
that allowed for exporting Ukrainian
grain via turkey rasul thank you very
much it'll keep us surprised of any
developments in the coming hours along
with Harry Fawcett and Kiev appreciate
all the reporting there